she just inspired so many people
everybody jumped up and
the wig came
here like my assignment is to make you
laugh and to make you feel Joy
you could say Sherry Shepherd brushed
off this on-air mishap
but this maybe wasn't a true accident
you know I love me some Sarah Jakes
Roberts things may have gotten a little
too real for Sarah while she was
preaching her wig began to slide off
get out of here
yeah it seems more likely that the
comedians paying tribute to Sarah's
viral moment I was so inspired by Sarah
Jakes because I know how that happens
and so she just inspires so many people
everybody jumped up in the week
oh shoot the ring
of course Sherry's audience couldn't get
enough
it came
it came up and you sitting there and
what you gonna do I like to have fun
yeah I think that we are going through
so much today sometimes our Spirits are
just hurting and you see that so much so
sometimes you just want to turn on the
TV and feel better than when you came
the show gotta go on
can you just you just you just gotta do
it and take a job
it just goes on
one of them days happy Monday everybody
The Show Must Go On this is the first
time in my career that I've never felt
nervous because I know that I'm supposed
to be doing this since your talk shows
debut last year Sherry's made it her
mission to bring laughs to daytime it's
even part of her theme song
[Music]
I think that people find me relatable
I'm that friend that you hang out with
at the bar I'm the cousin I'm your
sister I'm your auntie I'm your mom and
I think that people feel like yes Sherry
is there but she's been through it I am
here and I want to show women that you
can do this too you can be seen speaking
of feeling seen the people have spoken
and Sherry was renewed for not one but
two more seasons I was panicking a bit
uh before we started the show going how
am I going to be different everybody has
a talk show what and I learned you're
enough that's how you're different you
have to trust in who you are and what
you bring is enough but before season
two kicks off Sherry's got big plans for
summer 23. I think I'm getting my
boobies down I'm getting a little
reduction because my back is starting to
hurt we had a little bit of a wardrobe
uh snafu in daytime you can't have this
much boob out that's a big one yeah just
for my health and for everything else
laughter is clearly the best medicine
[Applause]
[Music]